[Musique]
au nord de la région nous retrouvons
pauline l'apprenti pâtissière alors on
se retrouve à montargis et là ça
commence à se terminer très très très
serré dans quelques mois ça va être un
jour j'ai et donc je continue à faire le
tour des spécialités de la région centre
mais de là à montargis la praline de la
maison mazet est une institution
racontera la gestion juste devant la
maison la prime alors pauline a rendez
vous avec benoît dijon le dernier
descendant de la famille mazet enchanté
je suis ravi de vous rencontrer on
l'interrogé et ben très très bien venez
goûter une prime d'abord parce qu'on a
besoin de se dire quoi que ce soit bien
obligé de passer par toujours à chaque
fois les larmes quand on la coupe
historique de la maison rue des vacances
cette boutique est un lieu chargé
d'histoire partie ici c'est un endroit
tout à fait symbolique puisque nous
sommes en face à des cds est d'accord
l'endroit où grand père a positionné le
magasin en 1920 il avait acheté la
maison en 1903 et en 1920 il s'est
repositionné dans l'axé de la sas est
ancré dans ce décor rodéo boutique
voilà le magasin est ici donc c'est ce
qui se passait en 1920 donc c'est une
maison très ancienne vous voyez un cd
maisons à colombages à la de chaque côté
puis sun nah aussi et puis ça c'est
l'immeuble des pralines avec les
vieilles voitures de l'époque voyez
c'est signé un statut de mirabeau et
l'intérieur du magasin n'a pas du tout
bougé depuis
traître et la recette de ce petit trésor
sucrée elle non plus n'a pas bougé
depuis 1636 1636 c'est l'époque où le
cuisinier on appelait ça l'officier de
bouche duc de praslin était un ministre
de louis xiii et qui a été le premier à
griller des amendes et du sucre dans des
poêlons on les a offerts dans les salons
du duc de praslin
on appelait ça les pralines et nous
avons garder l'appellation prace line
avec le s qui signifie bien que
l'origine du mot praslin c'est ça vient
de mots prat cela typiquement bien
notre pradines c'est la vôtre exactement
lorsque je propose ils vont ils faire un
petit tour à la production à l'atelier
pour voir comment ces produits les
pralines et d'un très bon ok on est va
prendre la voiture nationale
[Musique]